اعلن الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان انه
بناء على خطوات فنلندا ووفاء بتعهدتها
قررت انقر بدء مراحل الموافقه على انضمام
هيلسنكي
واضاف الرئيس التركي في مؤتمر صحفي مع
الرئيس الفنلندي بانقره ان تركيا قررت
البدء بالعمليه البرلمانيه لقبول انضمام
فنلندا للنيتو مشددا على ان دعم تركيا
لعضويه فنلندا في النيتو مهم للغايه من
جهه قال الرئيس الفنلندي ان من الجيد سمع
خبر قبول تركيا انضمام فنلندا الى النيتو
والعمل على التصديق على عضويتها
معنى من امام المجمع الرئاسي في انقره
مراسل للجزيره المعتز بلا حسن اذا حسم
الموضوع
والاجراءات القانونيه التركيه لقبول
انضمام فنلندا للناتو ستبدا
صحيح حسن كان هناك
رسالتان لكل من فنلندا والسويد في المؤتمر
الصحفي الذي عقده الرئيسان التركي
والفندي طبعا الرسائل هي من الجانب التركي
فنلندا بانها ابدت
نيه صادقه بحسب المقال الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان فنلندا ادت نيه صادقه فيما
يتعلق بالمخاوف تركيا التي وضعتها خلال
اللقاء الثلاثي والاتفاق الثلاثي الذي وقع
في مدريد سابقا بين السويد فنلندا وتركيا
فيما يتعلق بانضمام فنلندا والسويد الى
حلف شمال الاطلسي ايضا الرساله الثانيه
للسويد كانت بانه لا مشاكل يمكن ان تعترض
طريق السويد في الانضمام الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي الا ما قالته تركيا وهذه المشاكل
هي موضوع عدم اتخاذ السويد موقف ممن تصفهم
انقره بانهم منظمات ارهابيه وفي مقدمتها
حزب العمال الكردستاني الرئيس التركي كان
يتحدث عن ان حزب العمال الكردستاني
المنظمات الفرعيه له مثل الوحدات الحمايه
الكرديه يقول الرئيس اردوغان انها تنظم
مسيرات في العاصمه السويديه وانها اي
انقره طلبت من السويد بتسليم لائحه من 120
ممن تسميهم انقره بالارهابيين ولكن السويد
لم تسلم في المقابل فان فنلندا ابدت جهودا
صادقه بحسب الرئيس التركي وهذا ما جعل
تركيا توافق على انضمامها الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي العمليه الان حسن هي ان البرلمان
التركي سينظر في هذه المساله خلال الفتره
المقبله شكرا لك المعتز بالله حسن حدثتنا
من انقره